in the wake of 9/11 we didn't put
pressure on the Muslim world to reform
you and I got our civil liberties eroded
bro we got the creation of the TSA so we
could stand on longer security lines we
got the scooping up of metadata and I'm
guaranteeing you there was a lot more
than metadata it's being scooped up I am
Nick Gillespie with Reason TV and today
we are sitting down in Nashville
Tennessee with the best-selling author
Brad thore he writes the Scott Horvath
thriller series the most recent in a
long list of New York Times bestsellers
as foreign agent Brad thanks for talking
to us thanks for having neck so let's
get right into the latest book for an
agent talk a little bit about the plot
which runs through Syria and talk a
little bit about your serious
protagonist Scott Horvath a former
special ops guy in a V SEAL who is now
in a kind of private security yeah so
Harvick is a throughout the series of
books and my books are written as
stand-alones so you can pick up at any
point in the series enjoy the book this
is what you're 12 through 13 actually
it's my 16th 16 yeah 16 so you think you
can pick them up anyway it's one of the
publisher said don't ever cannibalize
your sales you don't want somebody to go
into the store looking for more one and
all there is this book 5 I did buy a
Patterson yes I'm not worried about
Patterson paying is a electric bill this
winter so har Beth is a seal who comes
the attention of the Secret Service
during a presidential visit by water and
he distinguishes himself and they invite
him to come into the White House to help
bolster their counterterrorism expertise
but this is a real apex predator the
president realizes this is crazy this
guy should not be on defense puts them
on offense kind of as his go-to guy and
as I watch the rise of Blackwater and
some of these other private military
corporations in got to have more friends
in the intelligence world
I saw private spying as being the next
big thing in a particular Defense
Department at one point did this because
they felt they weren't getting effective
espionage out of the CIA so they hired a
private group and I thought okay this is
interesting a guy CIA can use president
can use blah blah blah anyway a foreign
agent is all about the Russians trying
to prop up the Assad regime and not
being able to tackle Isis
and the rebels trying to take down Assad
so they're trying to trick the u.s. into
coming and fully committing in Syria
your books define page turners I mean
they're really great and we're going to
talk a little bit in particular about
hidden order which is a great book from
a couple years ago about the Federal
Reserve
that's a thriller is I mean it that and
you know like Dickens has nothing on you
if you turn the federal reserve I put
that on the back of the next book but um
you know do you worry about that kind of
I mean is how real is this stuff and how
much of it is you know just kind of a
projection from you know a couple of
like route elements
well I think it's I think it's a big
deal it as you and I are doing this
interview we've heard all the stuff
about the Russians tampering potentially
with the upcoming election there's the
whole thing about is Assange and
WikiLeaks a tool of the Russians there's
a lot of interesting stuff with Snowden
you know if you're you're trying to be a
whistleblower and you want freedom China
would not be the first place I would run
to and then the Russians say well I
guess we'll take ya you know so there's
a lot of interesting things that the
Russians haven't stopped being the
Russians they may no longer be the
Soviet Union just like acorn is no
longer acorn anymore
so I think it's very very much happening
on our doorstep right now particularly
just within the last 48 hours of this
interview the talks between the US and
the Russians broke down a brush working
together over there
so I I try to predict Brad Meltzer who
I'm friendly with was a great author
Meltzer had said that a thriller writers
job is to beat the Headroom and that's
what I try to do with these thrillers
and this it also you know kind of
thinking about this interview and
reading your books the one that it
reminds me also of the the book and the
movie three days well I guess what seven
days of the Condor three days for the
movie got a yeah slow it down but in
that Robert Redford's character plays
somebody who reads spy novels for the
CIA to kind of come up with plots and
you've actually done something similar
with the Department of Homeland Security
can you talk a little bit about what you
know how you know why would the you
don't have actual military experience
you are not a former SEAL yourself and
yet you're talking with government
officials about you know possible plots
and threats right so that was called the
analytic
red cell unit and it was stood up very
soon after Department Homeland Security
opened its doors so in the wake of 9/11
before the 9/11 Commission report the
federal government particularly some
very wise people there said the reason
we got hit is because we have no
imagination one of my biggest complaints
and I got a lot of them about the
federal government is that they're
always fighting in the rear view mirror
or looking backwards not looking forward
and they realize this so they said what
we need to do is get people who don't
think like the Pentagon who don't think
like the CIA let's bring in creative
thinkers from outside DC and brainstorm
with them so I got invited Meltzer again
another guy that got invited Michael Bay
who directs the Transformers movies did
the Benghazi movie and they brought us
in is they have any you know I'm
thinking Don DeLillo a great literary
writer in one of his books I think it's
running dogs there's a moment towards
the end where two characters are looking
at the World Trade Center and imagine it
being blown up and this would have been
written in the 70s maybe the early 80s
did they have people like that that they
have people kind of from the left who
also write or talk about terrorism and
they they had a wide variety so it was
not ideological it was strictly based on
creativity in what was amazing is they
brought people in I always tell people
this is like Las Vegas of government
programs what happened in the red cell
program stayed there I can't use it for
my books but I do when they present me
with problems I use my mind the way
would for the books but they were
exceptional in that it's hard to keep
creative people focused and they were
excellent and they team us up with
people from different agencies I
remember on a coffee break I was there
with some guy who is some super-secret
spook and he was going through the
garbage I said what are you doing he
goes watch what I can do and he pulled
stuff out of the garbage he made a bomb
out of what he found in the garbage bic
lighter a rubber glove he said give me
your cell phone he goes to take the back
office what's going on your meeting with
DHS and people are wearing rubber gloves
and bringing in lighters I'm sure it's a
smoke-free facility like this is it was
very interesting what this guy was able
to cobble together so for me as a writer
who writes about that world it was it
wasn't cool to be closed let's talk
about hidden order that was the first of
your books that I
and this is a book where Horvath is
called in because everybody who's in
line to take over the Fed is
mysteriously being murdered and bumped
off talk a little bit about what you
were trying to do with that book and
this is a book that among other things
quotes long passages from Henry Hayes
let's economics in one lesson the devil
or the creature from Jacqueline yeah
talk to talk a little bit about that I'm
a big believer in less government is
better government and we don't have less
government now and so my big push is
transparency and I was I would talk to
friends who had no idea what the Fed was
and I would explain and I think it was
from creature from Jekyll Island where
he said that the Federal Reserve which
is a kind of conspiracist history of the
Federal Reserve and there there's a lot
of legit history and their hair was
formed that's why I love that book is
how it was they they sped out a Hoboken
New Jersey on in Hoboken god it's the
Hoboken train stations in the news right
in the last week - yeah private train
compartment belonging to a wealthy
senator and they sped out of Hoboken so
that all these powerful people wouldn't
be seen they went to Jekyll Island off
the coast of Georgia and came up with
the idea and formulated the play I mean
it's like it is like Mike Myers II and
that's why I married an actual yeah
where they talk about the you know in
the meadows
right right I but I thought this is
fascinating because it's about as
federal as Federal Express right there
is you know I had heard Ron Paul talk
forever about we need to audit the Fed
in blah blah blah in the hundredth
anniversary of the Fed was coming up and
I thought okay this is a great way to
give people a page-turning b-trees
riller but inform them about the Fed by
by weaving in this there's some other
kind of founding of America subplots the
murders are being committed similar to
what a group leading up to the
revolution I was doing things so that
was the idea did readers kind of talk to
or you know send a nuts like how this
really opened my eyes or this made me
start reading stuff this was a book that
broke through in the libertarian
community and that wasn't my that wasn't
my goal I wasn't writing for
libertarians I've got that streak in me
I picked things Nick because I want to
know more about them I spent a year
working on a book so I want to be
excited about it's got a
fuel me and learning about the fed it's
probably one of the highest points I've
ever set the bar for myself I said if I
can write a thriller about the Fed it
make it exciting yeah I've done my job
but touring for it like I wanted to Fox
News like what's the book about oh my
god if I say it's about the Fed right
you know all these juicy is going to go
a scattergram slit exactly so what I did
was as I said this is the next big
scandal you haven't heard of this is the
most powerful organization in the United
States they pose as a federal so I
teased it um but it really I don't know
if it was word of mouth or whatever but
in the libertarian community it just
went like this and I heard from tons of
libertarians it said I didn't know some
of the things in this book thank you for
writing about it yeah Rand Paul read it
and enjoyed it and I got to be friends
with him because of the book so it's
kind of neat because all of these books
I mean one of the things that is great
about them is that you mix a lot of
historical stuff there's a lot you know
there's fiction there's plot there's
something you know action yeah okay and
there's there's tasteful sex and
flirting and you know torture I mean
it's you know in a lot of ways it's it's
kind of similar to Girl with Dragon
Tattoo I mean there's a whole broad
range of things and then if we want to
get more elevated it's in the tradition
of a kind of Umberto Eco you know going
back to the religions the name of the
rose which kind of kicked off god that's
like 25 30 years ago of this rich kind
of historically infused popular thriller
fiction like detective plots and that
brings me to your 2008 book the last
Patriot which probably your most
controversial talk a little bit about
that because that plot is really kind of
interesting and it's kind of like
national treasure meets you know name of
the rose meets hidden order and whatnot
so the last Patriot a lot of people
don't know that George Bush wasn't the
first American president to go to war
with Islamic fundamentalist it was
Thomas Jefferson so when we when our
merchants would sail the high seas when
we were British colonies we were
protected by the Brits during the
Revolutionary War we were protected by
the French Navy right after that there
was no protection road and the Barbary
Coast pirates Muslim nations of North
cut verses around Tripoli and legit
modern-day Tripoli Libya that whole area
right in there and so they were
kidnapping our sailors as they were
traveling in the Med and they were
ransoming him back to us and they would
write horrific letters these these poor
hostages to Congress and at one point
John Adams and Thomas Jefferson met with
the Ambassador to to Tripoli in London
and said we have no beef with you I mean
Jefferson was the guy about you know
commerce with all you know entanglements
with none and Jefferson's and what's
going on here and he says well you're
infidels and it's written in our book
that you know it's our duty and our
right to take your possessions and
enslave your people and so we tried the
diplomatic means to to reason with these
people and it didn't work they kept
taking our people hostage again and
again and again and then they wanted
tribute so it wasn't just pay us we'll
give you guys back it's like a
protection rug and so when Jefferson
became president and this kept going on
Jefferson said that's it it's like that
line from Star Trek here and no further
so he sent the the United States Marines
this was their second there was a little
thing in the Caribbean the Marines had
done but this was the first major
projecting visitors I mean from the
halls of Montezuma to the shores of
Tripoli yeah in fact the sword that the
Marines have is called the Marmaduke
sword and that was given as a gift to
the Marines and so in the last Patriot
then you take off on the idea of that
there is a missing or a hidden there's
passage in the Quran chapter actually so
I've gone on TV and I've punched it up
with people apologist for Islam on Islam
and you know they say oh you're
cherry-picking the bad verses and I
always have to give my 30 second
elevator speech which is if you look at
the prophethood of Muhammad it's divided
into two place in two parts even Muslims
will tell you this he started out in
Mecca where he's preaching very
peacefully trying to woo Jews Christians
and pagans to his new religion then he
moves to Medina becomes this powerful
very wealthy warlord then he's not so
nice anymore that he's not let's work
things out then it's my way or you're
going to get it in one of the problems
Muhammad had was that he started
contradicting himself and his apostles
his disciples came to him and said wait
a second you said Allah through the
angel
Gabriel said this how can you contradict
yourself yet a real problem went away
for a couple of days and came back and
said well it's now been revealed to me
that if I give you something different
I'm just the messenger
okay if I give you something different
it Adric abrogates any contradictions so
what'd I tell you today wipes out
everything before
well the Quran is not organized
chronologically it's organized by verse
link so if you actually put the Quran in
chronological order you'd find the
peaceful stuff in the beginning and the
more violent stuff towards the end well
fast-forward to an article that I had
read about they were doing real life
they were doing repairs on a mosque in
Yemen and they found all of these old
parchments up there and they didn't know
what to do the Yemeni government called
in these brilliant German German
scientists they were dating it and
everything and then they happened to
tell the the Yemenis wow this looks like
it could be early things may be missing
from the Quran the Yemenis threw him out
yeah so I open the last Patriot with a
quote from one of Muhammad's disciples
where he basically you know you and I we
write on deadlines and things like this
where he basically set a deadline for
the writing of the Quran and said you
know Thursday at 5 o'clock quit bringing
in pieces of parchment because this is
the book it's done and when I published
this book which had been called The Da
Vinci Code of Islam Muslim people went
insane because I suggested that there
could be a missing chapter in real life
you can fictionalize Mormonism can
fictionalized Catholicism but Sam Harris
wrote a great piece at The Huffington
Post I don't often point to The
Huffington Post but a lot of same stuff
I like where he was called losing our
spines to save our necks where he said
we've given Islam a protected space in
the public square where they are immune
from criticism and if anything the
Reformers in Islam need the religion to
be criticized so that you can force
cracks so we'll talk about that because
and you have the book I think it was on
Glenn Beck and a couple other people
said that this you were kind of flirting
with a Salman Rushdie moment of you know
where you dead in a year Glenn said you
get in trouble I mean that obviously
didn't happen have a happy end in Saudi
Arabia Salman Rushdie come to mind a
little bit the death threats have
already started rolling in and the book
doesn't come out till midnight tonight
okay kind of a badge of honor isn't it -
but and you have gotten death threats -
how do you do you take them seriously
what what is it like as an author I mean
I get a lot of you know hey go you know
garden with razor blades but not death
threats what is it like as an author to
be you know I'm the kid on the receiving
end of that even though the death
threats have not increased they still
come in they haven't increased in tempo
the situation we live in now has gotten
worse particularly with Isis Wikipedia
now has a subcategory which we just
discovered a little while ago I'm on
which is critics of Islam which is
basically a hit list if you want to go
out and rack people who are you know who
criticize Islam in the problem with Isis
is is that as they continue to lose
ground for their Caliphate when they
recruit people online and you've got a
convert they're now telling them you
know what don't come over to Syria and
fight find a target where you are
whether it's a actual physical target or
whether it's a person so that makes it
more danger hod the jihad locally think
globally and make your gene oakley
exactly you were raised Catholic right
you a Catholic school yeah I mean I'm
not a raised Catholic and Objectivist
will talk a little bit about that in a
second but do you think Islam and is
there such a thing as Islam and is it
fundamentally incompatible with a kind
of classical liberal order that we have
generally speaking in the West and
certainly in the United States or is it
that you know just as you you know at
various points in Catholic Roman
Catholic history you could say okay you
know the church was an agent of
liberation of people and of peace and of
tolerance and of individualism or it was
actually putting people to death I mean
is are there many Islam's or is there
only one Islam and are we at war with
Islam or are we at war with Islamists
the problem with Islam is not Islam the
problem with Islamist Islamic
fundamentalism that said that's not an
excuse in fact I think it's an
incredible indictment because if you
look if you consider three of the major
world religions Judaism Christianity and
Islam
two out of three have had Reformation
one that hasn't is Islam or some people
argue it it had a Reformation which
actually is Wahhabism so error
it's the strain yeah yeah Abba some is a
is a huge huge that the Salafist will
help you there's a there's a big problem
within Islam and I'm it bleeds what I
try to talk to it with people who are
just not interested in it it really is
an eye bleed but the problem is is I
believe that if Mohammed came back today
Nick and handed out trophies for who the
best Muslims were Isis a get them
al-qaeda would get them they're
practicing Islam exactly the way he told
them to practice it so they're not
perverting the religion technically it's
the people that we like the moderate
peaceful Muslims who are actually
perverting it who are taking Jews and
Christians for their friends that's
that's the problem and without a central
governing body how are you going to get
a reformation in Islam you know in an
American context one of the things
that's interesting is you know Americans
particularly broadly on the broadly
defined right you know people look at
Europe and they're like oh you know
Europe is terrible but then they'll say
well Europe is the canary in the
coalmine for Islamic immigration and you
know all of that kind of stuff and yet
in America for the most part we have a
very different relationship with
immigrants and with immigration with
assimilation you know we're the best by
the way yeah American Islam world people
who follow Islam assimilate better in
America than anywhere else it's bizarre
the people are like oh you know Germany
isn't handling immigrants well it's like
they never have they've always had
problems with that France has had the
same problem England a little bit better
but problematic you know is is the
American experiment or the American kind
of ethos of of tolerance of pluralism
and of following the law is that strong
enough to overcome you know the the
problems that might present itself from
you know the most you know from from
people from Islam or people from Mexico
or people from Canada coming here as far
as Islam is concerned we're losing the
ability to fold people into our culture
and it's not the first generation it's
not the first generation of Muslims in
France that they're having problems with
I lived in Paris and they talked about
the the Muslims that came from North
Africa French colonies to come and sweep
the streets and all this kind of stuff
where you're seeing the problems it's
the first generation they have one foot
in the old grocery one foot the new
country
they show it's not the first it's the
second or third it's the first born in
that country the first generation were
born there so that's the problem so what
we're seeing here you know we have the
tsarnaev brothers who weren't born here
the Boston Marathon bombers but the San
Bernardino shooter the man the husband
was born here you know we've got the guy
down in Orlando so it's not their
parents generation and culturally with
the hardcore leftists that are basically
telling everybody that if your life
sucks it's not your fault it's somebody
else's that on top of the Wahhabist the
Islamic fundamentalist trying you get
listen we all go through a shiftless
youth you know at some point you're
never come out so that's Joe's some of
us never leave our youth but it is a it
is a toxic it's a weird thing where you
can do the experiment ten thousand times
in the laboratory in on the ten thousand
at first you get a spark so it's not all
Muslims we don't need to be you know I'm
not an apologist for the Muslim
community I think that's fully their
responsibility but this is something
that's going to happen more and more my
concern is it's going to and it's
already starting to its we had the mall
attack in Minnesota and st. cloud where
the guy stabbed eight people with a
knife which Isis had just called for
last month they're now telling people
show up at AYSO soccer games and stab
the kids they're saying go to quiet
neighborhoods go to nice neighborhoods
there Isis is now encouraging stabbings
then you've got the guy in they say was
nuts in Washington a week ago who shot
five people at the Macy's makeup counter
this is Israel we are now going to be
living like Israel talk a little bit up
because you're also you're a strong
Second Amendment supporter you're you're
very skeptical of the surveillance state
you know from that context is religious
or theological based violence is it
really like crime as opposed to say
something like the Cold War or Nazism
where you you know you can't recreate
society and put it on a war footing so
that everything is directed towards a
particular effort if what we're talking
about here are kind of random people who
you would not even try Nick this is this
is my problem
okay 9/11 happens where was the print
these were not guys from County
right in Ireland that came over and did
this it was very specific what their
ideology was and what part of the world
they came from what pressure did we put
on them in fact you know we helped
hustle out a bunch of you know the
sympathetic Saudis and stuff like this
when there was no air travel they were
allowed to go out and but the problem is
is in the wake of 9/11 we didn't put
pressure on the Muslim world to reform
you and I got our civil liberties eroded
bro we got the creation of the TSA so we
could stand on longer security lines we
got the scooping up of metadata and I'm
guaranteeing you there was a lot more
than metadata that's being scooped out
this week we're hearing that you know
yahoo voluntarily allowed intelligence
agencies to sweep through over emails
Yahoo emails Great Britain the the
intelligence services over there had
found a backdoor through iTunes but we
did respond and we responded by feet
embalming and deposing the Taliban in
Afghanistan and then sticking around we
should go to Iraq which was kind of an
odd non-sequitur from what I mean so
exactly that is and I talked a little
bit about that because I think a lot of
the times people would would look at
yourself and they'd be like okay you're
like a neocon ha I'm not did we respond
poorly by going into Afghanistan and not
certainly not looking for bin Laden but
then sticking around and not really
doing anything did we make a mistake by
going into Iraq and if we did then what
do we do now because we just put more
troops back in there and everybody's
kind of gearing up around Syria I think
going into Afghanistan was absolutely
the right thing to do because that way
it was it was I mean this is like saying
okay the I have to watch this is like
saying a high profile person was his
family was got carjacked and raped and
button and we know the neighborhood it
came out of but we're not going to go
into the major you got to go in and get
those bad guys I don't like
nation-building I think Ann Coulter as
philosophically disconnected as I am
from Ann Coulter had one of the best
lines I used to say you cannot give
people democracy on a silver platter
a silver platter they have to fight for
it they have to want it Coulter said you
can't bring democracy to a country that
has more goats than flush toilets so not
necessarily yes yeah that's classy maybe
it's my example but she hit the nail on
the head and it is that idea of
nation-building
or that we're not just going to go in
and get what we needed which was to get
bin Laden that's why we got rid of the
Taliban but then worship or yeah we
should have you talked to the operators
who were at Tora Bora there's a lot of
pissed-off people still because we
should have poured in there we should
have gotten them and that should have
been it now coulda woulda shoulda right
I mean whatever we kept looking for them
we found them in a bottom odd you know
do we kick the [ __ ] out of Pakistanis
for doing that [ __ ] you you hit this guy
you can't hide at eight-foot Arab next
to West Point I mean that in itself is
insane so the Pakistanis who are getting
all this aid and all this kind of stuff
there's no consequences particularly
under the current administration so you
know I don't want to go around and
invade countries and all that kind of
stuff and I understand that post-world
War two the Brits couldn't afford to be
the world's policeman at nature of wars
a vacuum and there's a lot of evil in
the world and if we didn't fill that
would have been the Soviets I don't want
the Soviets or the Chinese being the the
heavies you know and it is just it is
disappointing to me that we can't come
together as a nation and be able to find
a policy everybody's got a different
opinion but then we can say listen this
is important for us as a country I mean
I'm a big believer in federalism India
there's too much going on in Washington
it's too disconnected that we ought to
be making decisions I move to Tennessee
because I didn't like the decisions in
Illinois bro
I mean if if the states are the
laboratories of democracy Illinois's a
freakin meth lab I don't want to I'm not
I'm not going to be there with that you
know disaster and it's blowing up
constantly I came down here no income
tax Pete it's a very leave me alone kind
of place so for that libertarian streak
in me I like that my own damn business
let's talk a little bit about like where
you're you're kind of worldview and
politics or ideology come from because
so you were you were raised Catholic or
you went to Catholic school yeah an
Objectivist mother yep my dad was a
marine and the Marine Corps became a
real estate developer and my mom signed
me up for the Objectivist Center like I
think it was in eighth grade and I was
getting the newsletters and stuff and I
mean you know she gave me Atlas Shrugged
and we had you know all of the I ran
books and my mom was a real believer in
individual liberty shows my dad
my dad's not the both entrepreneurs yeah
so they like this idea but my mom was
really the one that was talking about
government and about the power of the
individual and I really believe that the
United States was set up to protect the
greatest minority community in the world
the smallest minority which is one
person the individual and that people
are inherently good there's bad people
we're going to need police officers like
it or not how do you I mean I think
you've described yourself as kind of a
Conservatorium talked a little bit about
like how conservative and libertarian
mixes in you and create something that
you think is particularly valuable for
people to consider militarizing the
police force you've got improved air
bags in your car you've got automatic
braking in cars this is when I hear that
term not that's necessarily from you but
I hear from a lot of people who've never
picked up a gun whatever if to me as
somebody who deals in logic it would be
insane not to take lessons we learn on
the battlefield and bring them into
police departments because the police
officers number one job is to go home to
their family at the end of the night
it's not to take a bullet and die for
people in their community they sure as
hell don't get paid enough for that so
if there are pieces of equipment that
and they look scary I get it people all
dressed in a certain amount of that
that's why the riot gear looks the way
it does it's supposed to be intimidating
it's why SWAT team officers are not
there to you know a handout pieces of
candy right if you've got a SWAT team
coming to your house unless they have
massively screwed up in which case that
deserves to be dealt right various guys
do they do you don't it happens
everybody makes mistakes it's part of
the human condition there's no industry
that doesn't make a mistake when you're
dealing with life or death you really
want to minimize mistakes whether that's
sixteen layers you got to go through
within an hour to sign off on an
operation you don't want to be throwing
flashbangs into a the crib you have a
brand-new baby you just don't want to do
that but I am all for anything that
helps a police officer get home to their
family in the law-abiding extra space
exercising of their duties so if that
means better bulletproof vests and
helmets and weapons and tactics and if
you know I don't want a cop to roll up
in a Crown Vic when somebody's got an
ak-47 is putting rounds on them if you
get a Bearcat its armored you can go up
and punch older by the way that's how
they got into the night club in Orlando
the post nightclub they drove an armored
vehicle through the shirt but then
there's also towns like Keene New
Hampshire that have Bearcat you know
armored transport transport for cops
were the biggest thing as people egging
houses I mean this let me ask you do you
think they would have liked have had one
in Columbine yeah nobody thought it that
was Columbine Colorado you ever been
true never in a million years would have
guessed that by the same token it's it's
clear that the police didn't act
particularly well and they did have a
SWAT team or they had certain types of
things a lot yeah a lot of lessons
meanwhile there was also protocol these
things that are basically disruptive
Black Swan game changers now the way the
cops work is you don't wait for the SWAT
team you go in right away so now you're
asking mr. magillicuddy who's the local
patrol officer he's in at McGillicutty
it's not 1950s but you're asking a
patrol officer with sovereign body armor
that cannot stop a rifle round his job
now is to go into that in Charlie I
think we've interviewed Bernie Kerik the
former I know Commissioner of New York
and he actually is pretty I mean he's
worried about literally the
militarization of taking surplus
Pentagon gear and giving it to people
who are not trained for it or don't know
and he would argue that there's an
overuse of a lot of these tactics which
should be reserved both for very
particular situations as well as people
who are specifically trained so that's
yes so that's that that continuum of
force and that's what police officers
get trained as patrol officers that if
this guy's got a knife we do this for us
you know we're going to try to talk
about it but you've got your taser
you've got all these things in the drill
box so that I wouldn't be opposed to you
know that because it does have a it's
when you see that stuff roll into your
neighborhood particularly if you're in a
black neighborhood where you feel you
know what's the guy who is the bank
robber from Massachusetts when they
asked him why do you why do you want
well from New York yeah yeah because
that's where the money is so this the
data shows that there is a
disproportionate amount of crime
committed by by black offenders the
police are going to work with they're
not they're not carjacking in my
neighborhood
so I have I see very few police grouse
where I live but that doesn't mean that
you don't have a community that feels
put-upon I mean I know senator Tim Scott
has talked about how many times he's
been pulled up others where do you say I
mean do you see conservatives and
libertarians this is a you know kind of
the late-night Bowl session that
conservatives and libertarians seem to
have less and less in common because
conservatives often time are very
traditionalist
maybe socially conservative libertarians
are kind of like leave me alone and that
there's a gap actually I think it's
changing so when you look at younger
let's let's throw it all to the right
and kind of put it under the very
tattered very now shabby Republican
banner right so you've got a whole new
wave of Republican voters who believe in
gay marriage where you've got older
Republicans who are more socially
conservative so I'm Pro gay marriage so
I'm not one of these super socially
conservative guys that's part of my
mindset part of the Objectivist radical
capitalists like I'm randon saying just
leave me alone let me go do my own thing
you know I watched Dennis Miller all the
time he's like I'll write you a check
much does it how much does it cost
here's the check just leave me alone
okay I don't want to be told that I've
got white privilege or this that the
other thing my grandfather worked for
the telephone company first person born
in this country in my family worked for
the telephone company played trombone on
the weekends to make extra money my dad
went into the Marine Corps to go to
college on the GI Bill my mom was a
flight attendant for TWA I mean you know
and so they worked hard you know this is
this is the thing I Milton Friedman is
one of my my favorite people in the
whole world if anybody watching has not
seen him totally destroy Phil Donahue
it's some of the greatest stuff but I'm
also very as Friedman was I really
believe that motivating people in a
family unit it were families are more
motivated than individuals to a certain
to a certain degree I remember watching
an old Friedman thing where some kid you
know we're all young and stupid Watts
was was proposing a hundred percent
inheritance tax that when you died
anything in your bank account all your
assets should go to the government not
go down in Friedman talked about how
terrible that was because
or how well-off a family is they want
their kids to do better and that's the
incentive for them to work hard and when
you remove incentive people don't or
they go out and blow the money on just
stupid stuff and it encourages this bit
wastefulness it's your money you do what
you want with it but the idea of the
family being something that really helps
to create a incentive I thought was
fascinating coming from him and it was
something I'd never heard until recently
and I like that idea yeah you you went
to college at USC and you were trying to
be a business major and UB ended up
becoming a creative writer what happened
there why did that happen
so I jokingly refer to my old man
because he was a marine as the Great
Santini my brother always lancing yeah
my brother doesn't even like sugarpants
arrival coffee it was my favorite
daughter I'm still sugar heavy so the
Great Santini again this is that the
American dream my grandfather first one
born here said he to my dad I want to go
further than me and then my dad said to
me I want to go further than me so for
my dad it was go get a business degree
and I did it to make him happy but I
hated it and I was in a economics class
Valentine's Day was coming in and this
professor walked onto the stage and was
so excited he had this great project we
were going to do you work in a flower
store chain you've got all these orders
for roses but there's only so many vases
and I said that's a [ __ ] this I'm out
and I closed my books and my friends
there what are you doing I said I'd
rather suck start my Glock then to be a
middle manager in a flower store chain
they said you know it's just an example
you have to go I said
I couldn't stand this and I mope around
my my apartment for a couple of days and
somebody said go to the career
counseling office and I did and they
gave me this great test they can get
online now called the strong Campbell
personality test not that you have an
aptitude in these areas but your
interests line up with people who
consider themselves successful and happy
in what they do and I scored off the
charts for writing and publishing I'd
always wanted to do that since I was a
little boy but the arts and my family in
our upwardly moving from the south side
of Chicago and trying to move up that
was something that made you better
rounded it was not a career path because
very few people make it so I started
taking the classes and then I chain
my major like 24 hours right before
graduation right and you worked with TC
Boyle who's a fantastic well-regarded
novelist who's also a man of the left
how you know just talk a little bit
about your experiences with him or how
you know how you learn from people who
you don't necessarily share a worldview
with and is he happy that one of his
prized students is now a New York Times
best seller and somebody who writes at
Breitbart calm or you know talk mostly
to audiences on Fox News by the way I no
longer have anything to do with
Breitbart comm I want to make that when
they went Pravda for Trump then really
and I knew Breitbart I drove Andrew to
the Scott Walker rally where we stood
outside the Capitol we had 60,000 angry
union people surrounding us I mean
Android been in my house I won't play
that game of I can tell you what Andrew
would think or feel because I think you
shouldn't do that I think his legacy has
to speak for itself but as far as at Tom
Boyles concerned we never talk politics
if you haven't seen Tom boil google him
I mean the guy's just this wild here he
lived in the first Frank Lloyd Wright
house built west of the Mississippi
larger-than-life personality we never
talk politics it was great we talked
about the craft of writing and about the
art of just living of being alive and in
you know almost that Dead Poets Society
sucking the marrow out of the bones of
life terrific terrific guy shared with
me multiple times proud of you great for
what you've done he's now retired from
USC and I think I can see myself one day
potentially going back to USC in later
in my life and being a professor and
trying to live up to that level of
making it about the art not about the
politics
you know a little bit about that because
you know art art is always intertwined
with politics and you you you can reduce
art to politics and it becomes
propaganda it becomes uninteresting
either to consume or to produce but is
there is there a lack of creative people
I mean you hear this a lot in
libertarian and conservative circles
that you know we just can't win the
culture war and it's kind of like well
you hate culture you don't like music
you don't like books you don't like
movies does the right wing again broadly
defined are they kind of Philistines no
and I will tell you I will
back - dearly departed Andrew bright
part which is Breitbart said politics is
downstream of Roger so we get all these
bright creative young kids that want to
go to think tanks in DC when we need a
mountain Hollywood we need them in media
and DC if you will in New York that's
where we need them so I think we we
don't steer our young people into the
areas in fact there's a gentleman I know
who had worked on Newt Gingrich's
campaign and Newt Gingrich frustrated
not just the frustrated president but a
frustrated novelist thanks written you
know it's funny one of my first pieces I
got two great pieces of fan mail early
on in my career one came from Newt
Gingrich saying that my perception of
the threats was better than Washington
insider think tanks and then Burt Lance
who was a Carter Administration member
who said you know Brad captures kind of
the nasty insider politics better than
any other author of read so I think the
right is not doing a good enough job
where we're steering our young people
towards the politics where it that's not
going to do any good if we don't have up
here at the cultural level and there's
you know you look at Gary Sinise and the
Friends of Abe organization out in LA
there's a lot of people on the right and
we need more people in the culture I
mean thank God we got David Mamet I mean
here's a guy who wrote the secret
knowledge and I consider myself somewhat
of a wordsmith I had to sit there and
read that book with my dictionary
because I was like what's that word mean
what's that I mean he's very very bright
talk a little bit of what if you're
you're early gigs at out of school was
running a show called travel traveling
light traveling light
talk about how you know what that was
about and how seeing things abroad kind
of changed your perspective of the world
and and what what's the value of that in
a world where you know we're constantly
being told everything is you know
between a and B and you know you got to
get on with your career you've got to be
moving forward and you shouldn't be
thinking too much about the world I had
worked when I was at USC leasing
apartments saving money so I could own a
semester abroad in Paris because I grew
up the French nuns were the ones I ran
my Catholic school so I taken French and
got the high school and was an easy a
they said you can take Spanish German
Italian or French and I'm like I'd like
to try French so is this like the order
the Holy Cross or something or sacred
art sacred or sacred heart so did the
same thing in college and thought you
know what I had to do something with
these years of just coasting on my base
knowledge of French and so went to Paris
and studied there loved it in the head
friends that said you know if you want
to come back we've got an extra room and
I decided I do something we joked before
the interview started that I did
something no American authors ever done
I moved to Paris to write a novel I got
three chapters into it and I quit and I
long ago took the United Negro College
Fund slogan a mind is a terrible thing
to waste and I shortened it a mind is a
terrible thing period because I had this
voice in the back of my head saying what
if your novel sucks what if nobody buys
it you're gonna take a year out of your
life and this is what you're going to do
don't risk the embarrassment I really
believe that that which were most
destined to do in life were often the
most afraid of and will try again and
again and again it'll keep it'll stay
there until we do it but I wasn't ready
and I shipped my laptop home I travelled
so all these young people traveling I
thought wow that's wild because the only
travel shows I see are for people my
parents age or people retired though
it's the Petrella tours right the Holy
Land and all absolutely Rick Steves
travels in Europe and things like this
and I said seeing America from abroad
made me a appreciate how good I had it
that was number one but it also exposed
me to new ways of thinking different
ideas I really realized that the mind is
like a parachute got to be open to work
and I thought if I could somehow convey
this convince people 18 to 34 don't wait
until you're retired to travel outside
the US do it now that'd be great so I
got back I was interviewing to go into
the training program at William Morris
to be an agent if you've ever seen
swimming with sharks that's what I
thought I was up against and I was on
the side trying to get Public Television
interested in this idea and I came down
to my very last interview at William
Morris which was with the head of their
television Department his name was Bob
Chris Donnie
and I had gotten that morning a call
from Public Television saying you know
we're interested we think we can work
with you on this and I told Chris tiny
in in this interview and he says listen
he says I don't think I want to be an
agent he said you're obviously creative
this is a great opportunity for you and
maybe at some point in the future we'll
work to
with you as agent client and I have a
great relationship with William Morris
Endeavor now it's it's funny to watch
entourage because that is you know Ari
Gold is supposed to be Ari Emanuel who
runs William Morris Endeavor Rahm
Emmanuel's brother I've been very rough
on as mayor of Chicago but it is very
interesting because I went out did all
the work I had to find the money I had
to make the shows but Public Television
got their cut
so I joke it was my first experience
with communism you know this is the
expert you were alienated from your
labor or at least the profit there was
always a hand in my pocket no matter
what was going on great people yeah big
distributor right well the distributor
got their cut too I worked with kind of
an outside distributor to Public
Television so it was very interesting to
see how that worked now the most
interesting thing of all was Gingrich at
the time was doing his contract with
America and he was talking about cutting
funding for the Arts and one of his
biggest contributors was in the office
next to the one I was using in the
Wrigley building in Chicago my dad let
me have a desk like back by the copy
machine as long as I promised to do work
for him I could do my stuff on the side
so it was kind of funny to be in this
position where I was you know you trying
to get something going on public
television but really as somebody wanted
to limit the scope of government was
glad to see the contract with America
and trying to rein in wasteful spending
you know more people are coming to
America from all over the place you can
see it on the internet you can Skype
with people you can is are we having a
broadening effect because technology
really has made a kind of McLuhan a
global village more of a reality
the men you talk about technology I
really have a feeling that we got sold a
bad bill of goods as the human race
technology was supposed to make our
lives easier I think it's actually given
us more time within which to do more
work I think we do more work now than
people did in the 1950s and also I'll
point to an essayist Andrew Sullivan and
now he's writing a New York magazine and
this month he's got a piece out that
said what makes us human what makes
Western culture in particular so good is
what we do with those quiet moments of
reflection well if you if you saw that
piece with louis c.k on conan where he
heard that Springsteen song he was so
overwhelmed with emotion that he wanted
a text that's our thing we fill the
silence with the text and he says no
screw that I'm going to pull
over any wept I think we're missing out
with that but as far as the ideas of
America for me it's like every time you
get on the net it's like drinking from a
firehose so I don't know how much of
freedom and the American exceptionalism
particularly when we have a president
who is watered that down and said I'm
sure Germans believe in German
exceptionalism so those ideas of what
make America great I think have been
kind of pushed down over the last seven
eight years I don't think were were
broadcasting those as much as we should
you know it's interesting because I mean
I I disagree I think in a lot of ways on
that and I would argue also that
somebody like George W Bush and I'm not
I carried no bags for Obama but that you
know Bush's actions which Obama
continued in many ways that's what
destroys American exceptionalism when
you when you you get into stupid or dumb
wars abroad and rain down destruction
whereas Bush was actually really great
on immigration and I think he has a he
had a vision of America as a place where
you could come and maximize your
potential yeah which is great absolutely
in even with the whole black lives
matter thing was really interesting when
I hear white privilege in black lives
matter and all this kind of thing it's
fascinating from an emigration
standpoint black immigrants to this
country do incredibly well because they
want to be here they want to take
advantage of the system so the idea that
America is stacked against a particular
skin color is Patrick Rudd how do you
and I agree that we need to you know be
able to say look there is a type of
American exceptionalism or America is a
particularly good country for these
reasons or particularly great how about
just do individual ISM no no are you
writing over through Iraq and then we
let them build their constitution on
Sharia law which has no respect it's the
individual that makes America
exceptional is that focus I totally
agree and I guess what I was going to
ask is how do you you know how do you be
a patriot like that without them kind of
falling into well we can't criticize
anything because there are people on the
right you know that are well you know
the minute that you say anything bad
about America then you know you're
you're as bad as you know
had a large sauce or something yeah you
we have to we can't fall into that trap
of of just saying well our sides doing
it so therefore it's okay
what was Jonah Goldberg who cracks me up
he's a very very funny guy he's
particularly talking about one of the
candidates now he doesn't like who's
become a master of retro at rectal
ventriloquism so he talks out of his
butt and it comes out of other people's
mouths because it's their guy I saw this
with the Republican primaries where
people the minute Trump clinched it
they're like all right well now he's our
guy and they won't criticize him anymore
and let's it's good would you go along
with anything your wife said or your
husband said would you not try to make
them better would you not point out hey
this isn't working right I I don't think
it's unpatriotic to say you know I
disagree with this and we're individuals
right that this country is a collection
of individuals we're going to disagree
we're gonna have differences of opinion
but if we can't air them politely I
that's silly
we should march in lockstep with our
government or a political party no you
talked about the the master of rectal
ventriloquism you you were somebody
again on the you know broadly defined
conservative libertarian conservatory
and right you were a never Trump ER I
was on the hundred d-list rifle let it
go never Trump errs and then you seem to
have changed positions about and and you
went so far as a kind of celebrated or
infamous notorious episode on the blaze
with Glenn Beck where you seem to be
suggesting like you know if Trump gets
elected and we got to get rid of them
maybe something should happen to him who
will stand in the way of Donald Trump
overstepping his constitutional
authority as president if Congress won't
remove him from office what Patriot will
step up and do that if if he overstepped
his congr and ate as president his
constitutional granted authority I
should say as president if he oversteps
that how do we get him out of office and
I don't think there is a legal means
available I think it will be a terrible
terrible position the American people
will be in to get Trump out of office
because you won't be able to do it
through Congress uh which those yeah
talk about that - yeah I mean it's
that's like never ever Trump right or
Trump eliminationism and that was wrong
I mean I think there was a
misunderstanding
and I said if if he suspended the
Constitution and we have the feckless
Republican Congress we do now oh that
won't even stand up to Obama and if they
allow him to suspend the Constitution
the only legal means to get my office is
impeachment and if they don't remove him
from office
what Patriot will step up and do that in
my mind it's grabba I didn't say take
him out I didn't say splash him I said
remove him from office so I'm a writer
I understand what I'm saying and what
words are grabbed by the back of the
shade and I could have gone on that
you're kind of like you know you're
going uh Henry the second on us right
like I was a turbulent priest or
whatever so who stands up is it a David
Petraeus no I don't think so but who
does that I mean because you'd have to
have cannon ball sized balls to say I'm
gonna go up against a sitting president
who Congress won't get rid of and how do
you rally people behind you to say this
is a just cause we need to whatever it
is we're all going to drive our cars to
DC we're going to surround the White
House and I don't know but it was not
violent but the problem is is the
alternative right these white
nationalist neo-nazis picked up on it
some shitty little blog wrote brad thor
and glenn beck talk taking out Trump and
then Trump's biggest mouthpiece Drudge
puts it up you know that we were talking
taking him out in that the words take
him out never came out of my mouth but
that's how insane and now on the
internet everything is about slash burn
salt the earth it's not enough to
chastise you for a difference in opinion
you have to be killed your livelihood
wiped out because you're you're not a
Gary Johnson guy I actually don't know
probably in a vote for Gary Johnson yeah
there's a lot of things I disagree with
Gary no I live just so you know I live
in Tennessee deep red state is going to
go for Trump I have an opportunity
though to help the Libertarian Party get
further than they've ever gone before my
friend Mary Madeline has come out strong
for sure now a registered libertarian so
now I have that ability to even if it's
just one more vote you know it's not
going to my votes not upset the
applecart but it can potentially help
the Libertarian Party because I think
that is a harbor that you're going to
see a lot of people on the right want to
become more involved with how we
reconcile foreign policy and said we can
deal with that later but I'm tactically
that's what I'm thinking so well talk
about the the metaphor that you used so
I started out by saying America you've
got cancer and there's two drugs
potentially you're looking at one is a
decade's old generic that's lost its
potency and it's likely going to speed
your death the other one has been
developed at a shady clinic down in
Mexico where all they've been doing is
working with growth hormone for Mexican
wrestlers and there's no proof it works
it could kill you it might do nothing or
it might cure your cancer you know I'm
thinking of Danny Trejo the machete guy
is pockmarked and all the gold selling
this drug but that was my thing and I
said we're at the point now because for
me never Trump was always anybody but
Trump so in the primaries even down to I
was hoping for a floor fight at the
Republican National Convention that we
get a Rules Committee a floor vote and
maybe bump him out because I think he's
he is his answer to everything has
always been more government it's always
been more government he is a thorough
New York liberal big government
progressive he's not a Republican he's
not somebody that believes in the rights
of the individual he has always used the
power of the state look at the eminent
domain thing in Atlantic City he is
always sought to use the power of the
state to advance his own agenda and
didn't care who he steamrolled this is
not a guy who believes in Liberty the
only time he's even said the word
Liberty is when he appeared at Liberty
University so this guy is I can't stand
Trump and I said okay now give you a
perfect example friend of mine trains
high-end military units and he said to
me Clinton Trump he says Brad we're
looking at certain death or extreme
danger and when I'm faced with those
choices I'll take extreme danger every
time what is a why is a Clinton certain
death she stands against everything that
I stand for she has come out and said
she's a progressive I mean she didn't
say I'm a Democrat she said she's a
progressive so she's for increasing the
size of the state and I told my kids
that DC is like Jabba the Hutt it sits
there the federal government I should
say sits there in DC Java sits in DC
gorging on everything and if you even
hint that Java should go on a diet then
he sends Boba Fett after you but he does
it in the form
a weaponized government agency so it's
the IRS it's the EPA telling farmers
what they can do with their puddles and
their driveways that's not what the
founders intended our government was set
up to protect the individual and now we
need protection from the government it
used to be the other way around so
Hillary Clinton is 100% again she's not
fit she doesn't want me to own a gun
she's against citizens you know I mean
all of this stuff that is just not what
I believe the country should be and I
have to look at this and say okay it's
either a hundred percent of what I don't
want or maybe ten percent of what I want
but at this point Trump's got the
nomination he's either going to get it
or he's not going to get it I'm going to
wake up on November 9th with most of the
country we're gonna have a shitty
president by the way just the way that
well we will leave it on that happen oh
it's like jazzy yeah okay well thank you
so much we have been talking with Brad
Thor he is the best-selling author of
the Scott Horvath thriller series the
most recent book is for an agent yeah
Brad thanks so much my pleasure thanks
Nick for raisin TV I'm Nick Gillespie